oui d'abord je pense qu'il convient de
revenir sur le sujet qu'on vient de voir
puisque dans la partie basse contrôlée
par les séparatistes
là il y a eu des festivités mais dont la
partie qui est contrôlé par l'ukraine la
partie nord de cette région d'une basse
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de personnes
qui ont tout simplement extrêmement peur
j'ai parlé au téléphone avec une
résidente de chasse tia qui est sous les
tirs de l'artillerie ce matin encore une
fois la station centrale de cette ville
est sous les tirs de l'artillerie et
c'est une femme qui m'avait assuré il y
a deux jours qu'il n'avait aucune
intention de fuir et ou de partir
aujourd'hui elle disait cup non je pense
qu'il va falloir partir effectivement et
que beaucoup de gens partent et parce
que il croit une escalade majeure il
croit une nouvelle offensive de la
partie des régions contrôlées par les
séparatistes manon qu'ils sont reconnues
par la russie et ont un soutien officiel
de la russie est donc le discours de
volodymyr zelensky c'est en ce sens
aussi le président ukrainien est plutôt
d'avis que cette reconnaissance des
soi-disant républiques séparatistes par
la russie n'est pas la fin de l'histoire
quand on considère cette reconnaissance
en combinaison avec le discours très
belliqueux de vladimir poutine hier soir
on a l'impression que l'idée de cette
reconnaissance est plutôt pour servir de
base pour des aventures militaires
ultérieure pour reprendre plus des
territoires en ukraine même si le
gouvernement russe aujourd'hui a affirmé
n'avoir reconnu pour le moment du moins
uniquement la partie d'une base qui est
actuellement des facteurs contrôlé par
les forces que la russie soutient
gulliver vladimir poutine a annoncé hier
soir un envoi de troupe baptisée de
maintien de la paix dans les régions
séparatistes
avez vous un retour de terrain certains
médias 1 confirme l'arrivée de chars
russes est ce que les militaires sont
arrivés finalement
on a vu beaucoup beaucoup de vidéos
circulent et avec des chars et d'autres
véhicules militaires qui circulent dans
les régions contrôlées par
les séparatistes mais on ne peut pas
confirmées indépendamment
si ce sont des forces russes qui
viennent d'arriver officiellement ou si
ce sont les véhicules militaires russes
qui étaient déjà sur place
sans que la russie l'avouer qui se
déplace il y en a en tout cas beaucoup
beaucoup d'activités militaires dans la
région